in june 2017 mobile roaming charges in
the eu came to an end
[Music]
since then european subscribers have
been able to make calls send texts and
use data across all eu countries plus
norway iceland and liechtenstein without
being charged extra in other words to
roam like at home
the current regulation will expire next
year
and we will take the chance to improve
quality of service for customers
the rollout of new technologies like 5g
and a growing number of phone
subscribers using ever more data mean
the old rules need a refit on top of
this the kovid 19 pandemic has shown how
reliant we are on communications
technologies
the european parliament wants to extend
the roaming regulation for 10 more years
and this time it's set to go even
further it would ensure better services
for customers by ending practices like
lower data speeds when roaming
it should be the room like at home
experience and it's prohibited
to lower the speed of service
telecoms companies would also have to
better inform users about the costs of
any extra services when they're away
from home and there'd be increased
harmonization for emergency calls
including free caller location services
throughout the eu
[Music]
you